I try to be very hospitable I like its
thanks for doing this but yeah I mean
for sure how is Mindy that must have
been fun
Mindy was great yeah oh my gosh yeah
just her just you know having the artist
background overall so right right like
starting off as an artist and then this
is a weekly podcast I released one every
Monday at 8 a.m. and is it mostly comedy
of the arts or what yeah it's it's been
primarily comedy it's so I was like let
me start a podcast with that in mind so
then it's just kind of grown beyond
Atlanta comedy and now I think I'm gonna
start maybe taking it just to I kind of
finally figured out the whole point of
it is just to learn right and like to
learn about the person and I found
that's what my listeners like and what
I've got the most feedback on is when
just kind of the ABCs of their craft
yeah
so that's and I mean you being willing
to do it is oh yeah perfect again for
sure a fellow podcaster of course yours
Tuesdays with stories yeah but um I
don't
I'm cool with
yeah yeah I mean a little more modeling
in there yeah now we're now we're
cooking with now where is is that you
divert to you like masturbation yeah
yeah I mean kind of like your I love how
that's how you break awkwardness it's
just what yeah something let me top this
awkwardness yeah something even more all
weird yeah well yeah thanks um thanks
for doing this if you could just say her
full name into the microphone please
yeah sure my full name is Joseph list
all right Joseph list welcome to the hot
breath verse oh thank you all so we're
start we're underway here we're here
yeah all right great we're doing it I
always get accept that moment where
we're like alright this is happening now
I'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah we're in there now yeah we're in
this present moment that'll never happen
again we are it's already over that
moment is over this is a new moment yeah
exactly get that one's gone now we're
inching closer to death
well it's exciting to have you on here
because you know we're here at the
right-click comedy festival who you're
awesome participant in of course thank
you and what I'd love to know just
because this is an Atlanta comedy based
podcast what is kind of your experience
with Atlanta Comedy overall um I don't
have a ton of experience I have some
friends from Atlanta I've before dear
Atlanta is the only city I've ever
missed a show in which was heaven years
ago I was opening for Nick DiPaolo on
the road the old punchline which is no
longer there
yeah they moves and it was like a
Saturday night and I was this is in my
drinking days and Friday I just had a
couple too many I was all hungover and
out of sorts I just didn't know what
time the show started I thought was an 8
p.m. show but is a 7 and so I showed up
like 7:45
mm-hmm and I just like heard comedy
happening and I was like what's going on
here and they're like the show started
45 minutes ago so I missed my set they
weren't you upsetting they still paid me
and so it wasn't a big deal but so
anyways I did that one week at the
punchline back in O seven or so uh-huh
and then I feature for my friend Tommy
John Egan here a few years at the improv
right at the improv yeah that was the
first time I saw you live oh cool was
when like I saw you had to kind of like
wrestle the crowd that was yeah that
makes sense I remember that
remember like they weren't really coming
around and then through that 20 minutes
I mean by the end you had them in your
hand oh wow that's how that's how you
actually control a crowd
oh so yeah I kind of forgot about that
weekend but now I'm remembering it as I
remember it yeah yeah yeah I guess I hit
something I forgot the weekend I just
didn't put any effort into remember it
well you're busy yeah yeah but I did
that and then last week I work for Louis
CK at the Fox Theater yeah and so that's
been the majority majority majority of
my Atlanta comedy experience and I'm
good buddies with Noah garden Schwartz
nice yeah and he's been on here
yeah a couple of got rob Hayes like so
yeah you went head to head with Atlanta
comic Clayton English yes I was I'll
hold a trivia spot in Atlanta comedy I
was defeated by Clayton English and I
just know formula day here or I did a
set in front of him I don't know yeah it
was the opener yeah yeah yeah so that
was really nice it was it was kind of a
last-minute thing but it was really nice
of them to have me and it was good to
see him yeah what's cool and just
hearing you in this present moment talk
about your experience Alaina comedy and
just the growth you went from I was at
the old Atlanta punchline to the new
Atlanta improv oh and then I was at the
Fox with Louie CK have you heard of
Louie CK yeah how did how did you become
his opener cuz this is an international
tour we've gone with him yeah that
happened it's pretty insane and I don't
really know he saw me at the Comedy
Cellar I work at the Comedy Cellar a lot
and he's there that's kind of his home
clubs main club in New York and I just
was doing a set and a lot of times those
guys are just in the room you don't
realize it you know Chris Rock is gonna
go on next or something happens right
anything can happen at any moment sort
of at that Club so I was on stage and
didn't realize that Louie had been there
had a great set I'm it's a such a great
club it's yeah I mean you do well such a
high percentage of the time there so I
had a great set and he was back there I
didn't realize he was back there
listening kind of sitting on the steps
waiting to go on and he had a couple
jokes that he really liked seems like
that was hilarious and then the manager
was like he really liked he was really
laugh he was asking who you are and then
we kind of chatted after and he like
quoted a Joe he was like is that joke
new or whatever
and I was like is that an old joke and I
wasn't pretty pretty new he's like oh
wow and then we kind of figured out we
were both from Boston I mean I know I
know everything about him right I mean
it's like a [ __ ] Idol of mine so
right right so that was really neat and
then I think he just has a he knows
comedy he's got his kind of his ear or
nose whatever you put to the grindstone
and he has that body part on the
grindstone and like he listened to my
podcast and he knows a lot of the kind
of guys of my generation or whatever and
so I kind of got a random about doing a
couple other times we talked about you
know politics or whatever the hell at
the cellar and then I got an email one
time just asking if I could open for him
an East Hampton and the Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving weekend out in the Hamptons
and I did the first show Friday night
and then Saturday we hung out all day he
took me in my fiance out in his boat and
went to his house yeah out in the
Hamptons and we watched comedy we
watched like Richard Pryor videos and
Eddie Murphy and we were like talking
comedy he was pretty insane in his
living room minutes lunch she was like
really unbelievable absurd and as well
as things were like I became very
comfortable him because he's a nice guy
and I know him from comedy and we're
yeah we started at the same age in the
same city so we kind of like have a lot
of similarities I guess mm-hmm and so we
kind of became quick buddies but I have
to keep reminding myself like this is
Louie CK this is insane
yeah and then that night he dropped us
off in the boat like my fiance and I and
he was like all right I'll see you guys
in a little bit and then I got wild food
poisoning not from what he fed us hi the
night before I got so sick I couldn't do
the show mmm which was brutal and he was
like don't worry I'll make it up to you
and then fun fact twist Jerry Seinfeld
filled in for me because second fiddle I
guess it wasn't so he has that place out
there right and Louie texted me was like
hey man Jerry filled in which was you
know he said it kind of tongue-in-cheek
but I made the newspaper in New York I
was in the New York Post it said when a
young up-and-coming comedian Joe Louis
got sick Jerry Seinfeld okay so anyways
that's how we kind of met and he was
like I'll make it up to you and then
months later he asked me to perform on
some of these tour dates and then he
asked me to go to Europe
to the Europe tour it was unbelievable
and we're still currently doing dates
now yeah man it's pretty uh it's beyond
dream come true because I didn't even I
was like Jim of knowing that guy and
having him respect me but to go to like
Europe and Paris and London and a
private jet with Louise pretty insane
unbelievable
what have you learned from this
experience uh well one thing I learned
is that I would like to be that
successful like before I would always
like if I could just make you know a
good living doing comedy that right and
then you kind of see how that goes and
you're like and that's pretty good I
mean the celebrity seems difficult and
unenjoyable to me but the private jet
stuff but I don't know I learned like
I've already knew a lot of been doing
comedy a long time so it's hard to kind
of put into perspective or exact what
I've learned on the tour but it's just
incredible just chatting with him and
it's just fun and amazing but one thing
is that he's a real artist and pushing
to do better and be better even though
you know he's obviously rich and 25
years in and reached the top it's still
trying to strive to be better and find
his own new things and stay an artist
and and go somewhere that he hasn't kind
of been artistically which is inspiring
and something that I would like to do of
course and he obviously is known for
like creating like an hour you know a
year type of work work regimen but like
you seeing him work night after night
like how different will the shows be
they're pretty similar I mean it's sort
of a skeleton there but he's adding
stuff by adding a lot of stuff uh-huh
new lines and changing up words and
stuff it's become I don't watch as much
because after a while you start you've
seen it so many times that it starts to
take away where you're coming like I'm
hearing a thing for the 30th time you're
started to be alright I don't want to
get in that zone so I kind of sit out on
some of his set now but he changes it up
quite a bit and it's always developing
he's always writing cuz that's how he
thinks and sort of is I think as a
comedian do you do you adopt that same
kind of work regimen are you like you
always have a skeleton birdy you always
like trying to go off on different
avenues
I'm definitely always trying to write
and do new stuff because not because I'm
trying to do it
a year or anything like that I just want
to it feels good to get a new joke
working to have a new bit it's the best
feeling in comedy and it rivals any
feeling outside of comedy as well it's
great to get those words right and get
the thought right and have it work so
I'm always writing but certainly not
trying to pump out an hour a year and
writing a movie in a play at the same
time right exactly his work I think is
uh certainly superior to mine but well
you've also I mean you're coming up on
16 years right yeah just about yeah yeah
okay yes I mean he's he's got a got a
head start on you certainly yeah but it
is your is your writing process are you
since you've been doing almost 16 years
is it more on stage or do you have like
a pen to paper type of I do both I try
to uh sit and do I definitely do more on
stage now than I used he does completely
on stage he doesn't write at all okay he
does it all
he'll have a thought he'll think about
acting kind of ponder it and listen to
sets and then kind of go up there he
doesn't do any pen to paper but I'll do
pen to paper I do a lot of writing in my
phone just if I have an idea okay but I
like pen to paper and then I have a
general idea but you end up end up kind
of riffing on stage a little more and
have a little more freedom to do that so
it's a little bit of both for me I think
well you've been I guess tore how long
you've been on tour in Louie now I guess
started in July mid-july I guess and now
it's October and the the tour is going
through the spring but it's weird is
this like Europe was constant of 17 date
we did like 12 countries in 17 days but
the unbelievable and then this is now
like we did Atlanta last week and then
there's like two weeks off and then
mm-hmm I think Chicago or something so
there's time off it's not as grueling as
write one was yeah so you and you're
also in New York which is where he's
based out of and interesting topic
that's come up on Louie is like there's
been these allegations of like this
sexual misconduct I guess for lack of a
better word is that like surprising to
you you being around them and knowing
I'm like that I know them well I don't
personally I mean I can't speak for him
or for those people but mm-hmm
there's a lot of rumors but there's no
actual
real allegations from a person there's a
lot of like oh I heard this and I heard
that and I think that I think that there
it's hard cuz people listening this
might say oh you work for him or you're
friends with them so you're defending
him but nobody has actually come out and
said he did I like I think one girl
talked about on a podcast and then later
took it down and even tweeted like he
did not do that to me or anything so I
don't think about it too much
but maybe it's just my own friendship or
biased I know I'm pretty well and I
don't really think that he's done that
and I think that people that write it
and tweet it they don't know either
right so it's uh it's frustrating people
just decide that you're guilty and I
feel free every time I see his name come
up on Twitter or Facebook someone writes
oh yeah he's a rapist or whatever and
you're like you're accusing somebody of
doing the worst thing you can do and you
have literally zero evidence of that um
and so it kind of bothers me that not
just because it's someone that I admire
or like but the idea of just going oh
yeah that guy he's this because well
there's it's not there's new yet you
have nothing to say so why don't you I
think you should just kind of relax on
that because you don't know what you're
talking about and and if you know yeah
it's a yeah I don't know but I feel like
it's it's tricky to talk about because
you'll get [ __ ] one way or the other so
and I don't know what happened so yeah
it's just it was just a string to get
your point of view of somebody who's
been around him so much and now there's
nothing like hung out his house on his
boat if like you got like a weird vibe
or whatever no none whatsoever he's a
thoughtful guy he's a great dad I've met
his kids I've been to his house in New
York and in the Hamptons and he's got
two daughters and his daughters are
wonderful and he's wonderful he's I
think he's a great great guy and
unbelievably charitable and giving and
just a really really great guy mm-hmm
and yeah I think there's a lot of rumors
and that happens especially in our
society I think people like to try to
take people down or point out a flaw but
I don't believe that any of them
is real yeah personally but I'm not an
authority and you know ya just might as
close to him so I thought I'd be good
just to get that perspective Oh
certainly really interesting yeah but we
won't make this all about Louie but it
is kinda it's hard just to mean like
you're saying you can't believe you're
in the Hamptons with this guy and
everything yeah but it's not like your
career up to this point has just been
like failure and then Oh Louie appears I
mean you've opened up for people like
Nick DiPaolo and Dane Cook here's
another one you worked with like yeah
yeah I've worked with Dane years ago and
yeah I opened for a long time longer
than I would probably have liked to it
but I got to work with stained and Oh
for which was when he was kind of
breaking really big at the time I was
exciting and awesome and then I worked
with Nick DiPaolo for years and then
Tommy John again was a good buddy mine
for a couple years and Gary Gulman as
well so I work with our model like in my
opinion I mean I think we just named
like five of the best comedians of the
last 25 years or ever really actually so
I got to work with all those guys were
pretty amazing are those opportunities
coming from them just seeing you on
stage as well yeah just personally like
depalo I worked with at the comedy
connection in Boston and then he took me
on the road almost exclusively for a
long time and then Gary Gulman and tell
me Johnny we're both good buddies of
mine they weren't hey if you're not
doing anything else come do this so I
did that for quite a while is that being
on the road like that is that when the
drinking starts to pick up I would I
drank at home and on the road with
family and yeah I mean I drink a lot
everywhere when did when did that when a
drinking start started probably after
high school I didn't drink at high
school at all zero yeah not it not at
all until after high school was 19 or so
which is late to me to most people I
think but um yeah and then I just
started going hard pretty after just a
few months of drinking I was like let's
see how far we can take this yeah
so yeah what a hard drinking for a long
time you know start comedy at eighteen
by nineteen you're drinking I guess is
there a correlation yeah well first I
would always try to not drink before I
think I had drinks before I started do
County like the weeks before maybe but I
would always shy I never I don't drink
before I go on and then slowly you're
like I'm a couple of drinks and then
you're like well let's see how drunk I
can be on stage
you know it escalates quickly so why not
and then there's times where I would
drink all day leading up to a show I was
at a point I think where the shows were
always sort of in the way of the
drinking I had that a lot mm-hmm
especially on the road because you'd go
someplace cool and you're like I just
want to go see everything and drink
everywhere and the shows just feel like
they're in the way I still have that
feeling now - drinking where the shows
are in the way of the fun or the
football game or whatever it is yeah
yeah you went to Georgia Tech game today
yeah yeah you like to go to sporting
events wherever you go yeah as much as
possible for sure yeah I'd love it were
you an athlete I was an I played
baseball and basketball and in high
school I ran and I ran a lot
cross-country winter track spring track
mm-hmm and still try to do athletic
things and I love them as soon as we're
done I'm gonna watch the Clemson
Louisville game oh very nice all right
yeah pretty good well for a little while
then where do shows yeah yeah the final
night here at red clay yeah yeah well
being hammered on stage and it's um
something I always like to ask comedians
on here is like an epic bombing story or
like even to the point where you get
booed on stage yeah I'm sure you having
a drinking regimen I'm sure some have
come up yeah epic bombs yeah well when
you're drinking it's much easier to have
a snap set and kind of lose your mind
and now a little more accepting of
whatever sort of comes and happens on
stage but yeah I've told the story a few
times on podcast but the most booing
bomb set was opening for Bob Saget oh my
god at the University of New Hampshire
in New Hampshire obviously and it was
like 3,000 kids in a gym and they were
just fired up to see Saget and the show
started about an hour late because there
was a problem with the fire marshal but
they had all the kids outside and it was
in like February in New Hampshire so it
was freezing and then when it was time
to start the show they were literally
chanting Saget and like stomping on the
bleachers and it was like a classic
comedy formula when the guy comes out
and he's like are you ready Bob Saget
and I was like and then there was like
well first we have an opener Joe list
and they started booing like immediately
and it was like 3,000 kids or maybe
whatever 1,500 kids however many were
booing but people
and really it was a it was a melee but
um but it was fun that one it actually
wasn't that bad because I knew that they
were kind of booing the fact that it
wasn't Bob Saget mm-hmm and it wasn't
really the material there was like I'd
listen to my material like wait a minute
boo booing like [ __ ] this guy and then
one point some guy yelled oh hey [ __ ]
bring out Saget that was actually that
was actually pretty enjoyable is like
well that was fun yeah not that I
condone that language but you're like
well if you're gonna throw a rhyme in
there that was fun
and Saget loved it he was laughing and I
was posed to be like 20 and I ended up
doing like you know 14 and I remember
turning to the side of stage be like can
I wrap this and they kind of had took
pity on me and we're like so I said
mercy and lip but that was definitely
the most booing situation I did comi in
a gym one time like a Gold's Gym this
guy that ran a gym had an idea to like
have comedy during it so as a bunch of
like you know bodybuilders behind me
like dropping the leg press and then
like you know married women unlike the
elliptical machine like headphones and
be like what the hell and that was
pretty bad so there was been definitely
a bunch of weird bad yeah I mean there's
always bad shows with the company yeah
that's that's why I always like to ask
comedians because we all have those
stories it's funny they the guys like
you being a commune and you're like show
to gold's gym that's a terrible idea
I'll do it right you know that was
interesting because this was like maybe
like two years into my career when I was
19 or 20 or whatever mm-hm and that
actually my buddy was telling me it was
his gig and I was like I'll open he was
like I gotta do a half-hour at a gym and
I was like give me 20 bucks I'll do 10
minutes in front of you and he was like
of course yes and so that was like I
wasn't even like a hell gig that I was
asked to do I begged my way on to a gig
at a gym it was pretty but I at the time
I wanted to now I feel like I'm past
that point but I wanted to do comedy
every way to experience the naked show
one time and I nice got me at a gym and
I've done it in like rock and I was like
I want to do every form of stand-up
mm-hmm and then after a certain point
that's no longer beneficial to I think
mm-hmm like doing bad shows is no longer
like oh this will help me really on I
think it does how long
to your career to take you before you
realized okay maybe I don't need to be
doing the 2:00 a.m. showed coffee shop
yeah probably a while I mean I think at
ten twelve year I think if you're making
a living I mean it's like all right but
if you're you know if you're not maybe
just keep getting in wherever you can
cuz it all helps I guess mm-hmm so we're
talking about okay the the rock-bottom
of comedy what was your rock bottom of
drinking well I had several and they
kind of kept going out on the bottom for
a while definitely I took a [ __ ] I
blacked out and [ __ ] I say [ __ ] this
isn't a radio yeah I [ __ ] in a girl's
shoe basically in a first date her
roommate I was like kind of a first not
a date but first time hanging out with
this one girl girl a and her roommate
was girl B and I somehow blacked out and
ended up in girl B's room and defecated
all over her floor and urinated on a rug
it was a whole thing and I felt through
a living room table as well and so that
was pretty horrible that was like the
only time I ever was like you should
kill yourself like a real thing of like
why don't you I didn't start
contemplating like how to kill myself I
didn't get that far but I was definitely
like people would be happier if you died
oh I just killed a mosquito folks as you
said died yeah as you said died you know
I'm yeah I try not to take lives but um
this mosquito found his way into my
hotel room and he's not welcome here and
if I was better able to get him out
without hurting him mm-hmm and
unfortunately they spread diseases so I
don't know what you know what [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] that mosquito he's dead and I
don't give a [ __ ]
you just prevented us from getting Zika
so thank you we could have had tiny
headed babies you think you're too small
to make a difference try sharing a tent
with a mosquito hear that it's an old
Buddhist quote and I like to quote
Buddhist quotes while killing living
creatures the opposite of Buddhism I
guess yeah it's fun murder fun to murder
and quote the Dalai Lama at the same
thing but anyways yeah so I like [ __ ] in
this girl's shoe and urinate it was just
completely shameful behavior
and I remember thinking like well I
better not drink tonight taking that off
and then ended up drinking later that
night so there was a lot of like just I
hated my I didn't realize till after
when I got sober that I really couldn't
hated myself deeply so um there was a
lot of things I mean I was never like I
never like hit any women or cheated or
crashed a car but I definitely just
acted like an [ __ ] and a buffoon a
bunch and just didn't respect myself or
value myself or my career really so it
was a lot of just like oh I feel like
[ __ ] and I was drunk or hungover for
most of the time mmm for like 10 years
yeah so I just felt like [ __ ] for a long
time just cloudy and anxious and a lot
of shame and depression all that [ __ ]
and so I just worked better for me to
not drink I'm just better sober than I
am drinking personally yeah and how does
this sobriety affected your comedy uh
it's how everything that's happened you
know like all the big things that happen
to my career happens sort of in sobriety
like opening for Louie and then I got to
do Letterman I had a half-hour special
and or a half-hour whatever it's called
and I got to do Cohn and all that stuff
sort of came in sobriety working at the
Comedy Cellar all that stuff headlining
having a manager an agent all that stuff
came and sobriety for me it definitely
turned everything around for me because
I feel like I was a talented guy and
doing pretty well you know I'm at work
and I think people respected me or
whatever but it took kind of sobriety by
car let's focus and try to really do
this and work it mm-hmm for me
personally because I was always a mess
I'm not a there's a lot of comedians
that there's like or there's a sort of
this thought that or aura that these
comedians are all like painful and
struggling and depressed but I couldn't
work like that I'm I do I write and I'm
more productive when I'm happy and
feeling good which happens a lot more in
sobriety that did and drinking for me so
it's definitely helped me creatively and
professionally it just helped all my
relationships with benefits your career
did it help like did you have goals at
the beginning of comedy or when you got
Sobers when you're like okay I want to
do Letterman I want a Comedy Central
yeah that was a big man Tommy John again
is a guy that really helped me with that
as well like setting goals because the
only goals I ever set for myself or like
I would like to be a comedian in Boston
I can be a Boston comic and then
eventually move to New York and then
work the road so I accomplished all of
those things which was another mutt like
epiphany in sobriety I was like well
I've actually accomplished everything
I've ever tried to do I just haven't
tried to do that much right yes so it
became a thing of like let me do
Letterman I'll just decide that I was
like let me try to do this thing and
then I was able to do that so then I was
like all right what do I want to that
sobriety led me to go what do I want to
do what would I like to kind of be and
let me work towards that as opposed to
just be like let me just try to be a
comedian which if your goal is to just
be a comedian that's not hard you can
just go to a show open mic or whatever
right
nothing it's easy but just to be a
whatever any comedian is not all that
difficult so you make the goal to be on
Letterman what did you did you cuz I I'm
in the middle of a goal like I want to
be on Conan that's my goal yeah that's a
goal I set out I have like thrown into
the air and I'm like okay now how we
make that happen I don't know but that
is now me reaching higher than I ever
had before right on Conan so like when
you made that Letterman goal is that did
you sit down and you wrote out like a
plan like how did you approach the goal
perhaps well I went to a tape I went to
a couple tapings actually but why would
one was Gary Gulman nice and I met the
producer they were there and so Gary was
like do you know Joe he's great and they
were like no and just gave me a car it
smells like all right well that's a big
Wow I'm gonna have the email for the guy
personally I'm here so now that was
helpful I got an itchy nose it won't
stop being a cheek I'm not on coke or
anything that's gone who's Boog or a
hair something they can't see it on the
podcast alright great sorry that was
just for you Joe so anyway so I kind of
had the guys email and I was like great
and then I also had the thing that helps
where I went with Gary and I kind
went through the whole things I was with
them so I was like oh you go backstage
you put on your suit you meet this guy
you're gonna make up I can do this you
kind of had that moment of you go
through you're like oh why not me mm-hmm
and so then the next thing was kind of
figure out a set let me get a set
together and I've been doing comedy
along x and y have five minutes for sure
I can get five minutes together so then
I kind of got the five minutes together
and then I kind of got lucky again I was
at the cellar again a lot of my career
revolves on the cellar and those
producers just happened to be at the
show watching another comic and I had a
great set and then they were like hey
it's us again nice to see it make sure
you get us that tape we like this joke
and this joke so that kind of helped and
then the other thing about the Comedy
Cellar that's helpful
is that they tape all the shows and you
can just ask for a DVD they'll just hand
it to mmm cool and then most people in
the industry sort of understand it's the
seller so there's some amount of respect
so great stellar nice and so it's a good
tape and so I just got them a tape and
Letterman was actually very difficult it
was a lot of back and forth it went on
for about a year and a half which is
insane yeah cuz they had to change this
joke you need to take that out and then
they just take a while to respond
because they're doing other things and
it's you know Dave takes breaks and then
Dave announced his retirement during my
process which really added a lot to it
it was a whole thing and then March
Madness goes on and then they're off the
air for that week so it's a whole thing
so took quite a while and then actually
I didn't hear from them for a while they
kind of approved a set and I felt like I
was gonna get on and then I didn't hear
from him for a little bit and then my
manager was like I think we met to move
on they're just not responding and I
remember telling her my minute at the
time I was like just get it a no get
them just say no I've already had 12
e-mails back and forth it's a year and a
half I've invested so much time and
energy I want them to write know you're
not on the show I was like just get that
I don't want to just fade out and be
ghosted right and then the next email
was a date which was pretty amazing they
were like oh it was almost like they
were like [ __ ] this [ __ ] idiots not
going away just give him a spot yeah and
so I got a date and you know it was
magical it was great I know you've
suffered from panic attacks a lot yeah
before doing Letterman the late-night
show
were you just a bundle of nerves like no
I ended up being okay and that was
sobriety and I kind of got really into a
lot of Buddhist stuff and meditating and
all this stuff that I'm always
dismissive of because I feel like people
like ice cream
Buddhism like now that I read a lot of
but like I got really into and you have
a tick not Han quote in your email yeah
which is amazing cuz that's who sort of
changed my whole life his books I've
read about you know 25 have one on me at
all times it's one over there I'm sure
and that is really helpful but yeah I
definitely was afraid of panic attacks
because panic disorder is something that
is inside you it lives in you it doesn't
just go away you just kind of manage it
mm-hmm so I had a definite fear that I
was gonna have a breakdown and lose my
mind on stick because I had the thing
I'm like I just we should Dave out there
and they're like the guy can't come out
he won't come out and then like that was
in my head but you have to just let that
go away but don't even let that manifest
itself in you and I just like we talked
about the moment I just tried to stay in
the moment like I had what helped me
stay calm was like and this helps in
life and it's I think it's good advice
in general where you're worrying but
something like well I'm not doing it
right now
like I'm worried about the set but I'm
like but I'm not doing the set right now
I'm sitting in my bedroom so I don't
worry about it now and then the car ride
over you're like wanted to where I
wanted now I'm just in the car over
there and then I'm like I'm putting on
my suit but I don't have to worry about
the set because I'm just putting my suit
on right now and so I just kind of
stayed in each moment which allowed me
to be sort of relaxed
leading up to it and doing my breathing
exercises and and then also I got some
great advice from comics where my friend
Nate bargatze I was wonderful red-state
Nate hilarious yeah I one of the best
yeah but he was just saying I was asking
people for advice he was like you're
almost beyond being nervous at this
point he's like you've been doing it so
long it's like it's five minutes mm-hmm
and my buddy Nick Griffin is a wonderful
comedian and guy him a couple weeks ago
yeah he's a great great great guy in a
tremendous community but he um he just
said he gave me great advice is he I
have the voicemail save he said my
advice is he's like you don't need
advice from me there's nothing I can
what am I supposed to
do you know mm-hmm you don't need advice
you know you'd be second everyone has
great sets that's a great crowd they're
hungry and it's weird because late night
you get hyped up and but it's really
just a comedy show and you're doing five
minutes it's like a short set for a hot
crowd so it's like you're kind of just
going all right and then you have to
worry about TV just worry about the
people that are there and they want you
to do well everyone that's there wants
you to do well and you want to do what
everyone involved wants you to do well
except the people in the internet but
they're not there at the time Jim
comment yeah exactly so I was actually
pretty calm and relaxed and it was
almost bizarre was almost like a weird
experience where I was like I guess I'm
gonna do this not particularly nervous I
mean I had energy going and right I was
anxious to get out there but I didn't
feel nervous I wasn't close to panic or
anything like that I just felt like oh
this is cool and amazing and crazy
mm-hmm I felt really calm made me
neither the right word cuz you were
still are on TV so you're jacked up but
I felt very at peace it was really great
and you mentioned breathing exercises
yeah could you could you kind of expand
on that a little bit breathing exercises
is a weird term I guess just just
focusing on my breath it wasn't
breathing exercises I might wanna make
it sound like I was giving birth maybe I
could learn to learn just kind of
focusing on my breath my in-breath and
my out-breath that because you're are
breathing through all these thing it
feels like you're not because you're not
consciously thinking about it because
you're just kind of in a panic mode and
that happens not even just in anxious
situations but when you're talking or
hanging out that your body is breathing
it's just second nature or third or
fourth nature whatever the hell nature
it is you're just not conscious of it so
it can be calming to kind of sit and and
kind of feel your breath like almost
physically feel your breath going
through your nose and in your diaphragm
and lungs it can kind of almost
instantly calm you down which is the
thing that tick non-han is always sort
of talking about and writing about and
so that really helped to kind of get
away from the noise and just be like and
also that you're at home in your body
even though you're in this crazy
situation your body is still your home
and that's where you are and it's still
just you you know you're always sort of
home in your own body even if there's
chaos going around we will you do it for
like a count
like we do like inhale for seven and
exhale for seven not me personally but
that's certainly a thing that people can
do I guess I have done that at times or
but just kind of just taking a moment to
be like mmm I'm breathing and I'm a
human being and I'm alive and it's
definitely helpful okay yeah is this is
this kind of lifestyle something that
replaced the drinking um yeah in ways I
mean I try to be conscious of it and I
wanna I mean I'm still a anxious nervous
guy who's self-conscious and insecure I
don't want you to sound like I don't
know sound like I'm you know but yeah I
try to do it consciously throughout the
day and actually I would get nervous or
anxious and stuff mm-hmm
have you done that your whole life for
just when you found sobriety you found
like an alternative no just after
sobriety I was like I always I always
wanted to be into that I would do yoga
and stuff like that and I always wanted
to kind of be into that because I've
always had anxiety and been nervous my
whole life from as early as I can
remember which is kind of strange I
realized later for like a four-year-old
kid or a sixth girl to be like just
nervously so yeah I kinda went to the
bookstore and the first book I got was a
book called happiness by tick not how
and I was like how that seems like
something I'd be I want to be happy and
so I kind of started reading all those
and got really into that you just you
just had a feeling that book would be
good for you well I went to like the
Eastern philosophy as you were searching
Eastern religion yes your religions or
whatever it is huh and yeah I like saw
happiness I'm like oh that's what I'm
looking for and also I was like tick nah
nah just seem like that seems like an
asian guy didn't know what they're doing
over there and so I got that one and it
was really uh very applicable and easy
to understand and read has that
mindfulness helped to your comedy as
well I think so I think just being able
to be relying and happy more where I'm
like let me get some work done you know
I want to try to I think so yeah I think
it's all sort of benefited all aspects
of my life yeah because we need when you
did the show the first night here when
Adam at relapse here for the red clay
festival there's drums on stage and
you're doing a set and then you just
kind of kind of gravitate to
wrong yes I guess just being in the
moment and just flowing yeah I just kind
of felt I just wanna I always want to
hit drums and then it was just a silly
weird said anyways it's also we were the
festival like this is a lot of comics
there yeah and so you kind of get
self-conscious doing your material you
want to be silly kind of make them laugh
and that particular show there was about
15 house members 15 comics so late it
was the Late Show and it was late yes I
was like let's just be silly and fun and
and I did actually have a moment of like
I want to play the drums but I don't
know if I should and I was like well if
I don't someone else is gonna later and
then we got this dammit I wanted to play
the drums and I'll be jealous that I
decided not to write let me get over
there and oh you actually played the
drums like do you play drums like I know
such a tiny a minimal amount I know how
to kind of keep a beat okay there's that
self-consciousness come yeah I mean I'm
not playing you were playing Oh like
thank you it sounded legit
oh thanks a few people have said that
but I think if there was a drummer there
they wouldn't be like get out of here
you piece of [ __ ] so there it is yeah
it's coming back out yeah yeah yeah well
um before before we get out of here man
thank you so much for doing this is fun
again by the way I love talking about
myself good yeah good I don't know if
you're gonna be too too cool though I
don't know how no success you're like
I'm opening for Louie now I don't need
to be doing this no no I'm happy so what
is we talked about you start any
creating goals and you now achieving
those goals
yes so what're you clearly have high
standards for yourself what are these
new goals yeah it's it's hard figuring
that up because like Letterman was like
a dream to tuck here I was young and
then cone and I grew up watching so I
want to do Conan I got to do that yeah
and then I guess an hour special at some
point I mean I grew up watching HBO our
specials I don't know that seems more
exclusive now I just want to I think a
lot of comics kind of have this goal of
performing to a group of people that
came to see me as opposed to just went
to see comedy mm-hmm
that would be ideal and it's hard I have
to like figure it out but I don't think
I don't want to rush into like I want to
do this or that
I kind of am enjoying a trying to do
well and be as funny as possible and
then I try to have things outside of
comics you all want to be a good you
know husband and son and friend and
citizen and so I'm trying to do all of
those things while still creating good
material
I like albums I grew up with albums and
liking people's albums I'd like to have
a body of work that's sort of like
annual maybe not every year but a year
and a half two years I just put went out
and okay a couple months ago it's called
are you mad at me and check it out
I'm proud of that so I'd like to have
like Louie described one time you know
especially it's like your comedy career
should be like you're writing a book and
these specials or albums are like it
each one's a chapter so you can kind of
go through and kind of hear what the
person was doing right and I'm a big
music guy too so it's like I'd like to
just have I'd like to do specials as
well but I really liked an album I liked
the idea of sitting there in a dark room
and listening to it and feeling like
you're there so I'd like to have you
know sort of annually quality albums and
my podcasts I'm really I really like and
enjoy doing so I wants a lot of room oh
thanks yeah it's Tuesdays with stories
with Mark Norman's on there as well yeah
it's real fun and silly and irreverent
and it's just ridiculous we're just
having fun so yeah but people seem to
really enjoy it so I want to keep doing
that and I've always wanted to this is
something I wrestle with I've always
wanted to be like a filmmaker when I was
really young and I'm like I should try
to pursue that and write but it's like a
Scorsese yeah that's something that's my
sort of my guy Woody Allen Scorsese I
love those guys uh-huh
Woody Allen now his accusations a little
more I guess similarly we don't know the
answer but that one seems a little more
legitimate he has actual accusers right
yeah but anyways then we'll go back to
that subject but but anyways the art the
work I love so you're just thinking
outside of comedy a little bit yeah so
it's one of those things where it's like
oh yeah 34 what are you doing you didn't
go to film school but I'm like well why
not why not try to pursue that so that's
something I'd like to try to do or
whatever what are you waiting on I'm
just lazy generally oh yeah so I can
start doing I've made a bunch of weird
videos and
[ __ ] but mm-hmm so that's something I
guess I should work on that was a nice
nugget that Louie dropped you right
there and maybe of from Louie or others
super successful people you've worked
with are there any other kind of nuggets
of knowledge that you've kind of been
able to apply to yourself
I guess I've just collected so much
stuff because you just it's just wisdom
I guess you kind of gain stuff from
talking to these different people and
everyone but I guess there's probably
more but I had never liked coming to my
mind right now that was a fun one that
was a good one but no no that's fine
yeah nothing comes off the top of my
head but definitely just trying to
continue to be a good comedian what I
consider a good comedian hopefully my
peers do and I think they do it
lieutenant
yeah good absolutely man so ya wanna
yeah be funny and a good person but you
want to be the guy it's cool to open for
Louie but you're like I want to be in
the lights yeah yeah and I'm headlining
a lot of my own shaman I'm on the road
most of the time I'm headlining my own
shows I don't want to make it sound like
I'm just doing eight minutes for Louie I
mean I'm missing a bunch of Louis shows
to headline my own shows and stuff so
I'm out there and trying to put together
I got kind of a new 45 or so from the
album so I just want to thank you camera
at that and try to do know one of those
well please let let the people know
where they can keep up with you and all
that jazz ah Twitter and Instagram I
love instagram at chill list comedy I'm
very proud of my Instagram account at
chill list comedy on both of those and
then Tuesdays with stories my podcast is
free every Tuesday on iTunes it is a
comedy podcast please don't take any of
it serious yeah those are those and then
my album is called are you mad at me and
that song I wherever the hell to sell
albums great well before we get out of
here is there anything else you want the
world to know I love you thanks for
listening and life is very enjoyable and
have fun out there everybody all right
Joe list thanks for being a hot breath
man they still appreciate it yeah thanks
beautiful yeah